so welcome uh today I'll gonna explain
to you how we use Python to enable the
next generation of computer chips
I'm Tim Hoffman I work at Cloud size as
a simulation architect I'm a father of
two children and in between I'm a core
developer of micro.lib
so uh
before we can get started to understand
the relation between today's python
tomorrow's computer chips we have to go
into the past
and we'll get to know this guy
this is Carl zayas
175 years ago
he was a device maker so he built some
mechanical and optical devices and in
particular he also built microscopes and
at that time building microscopes was
basically a trial and error thing you
had some glass lenses laying around on
your table you took some put them
together checked does it make a good
picture no I addressed them
still not a good picture okay I'll take
something out put something else in so
this was not very efficient and he said
there has to be a better way of doing
this we should be able to really
understand how a microscope works and to
calculate that and in fact
then he founded a company and it was a
great success because they could
determine dynastically built good
optical devices
so um
this company grew and he decided that
after his death this company would be
transferred to a foundation
and the foundation has three goals first
goal is make sure the company stays
alive
second goal is
promote the Social Security of your
employees and third goal is fun science
and research from what you earn with
your company
and at that time this is a really strong
proposition of value so
it's clear if the company doesn't
survive there's nothing else to do so
this is the first thing second thing is
care for your employees
and if there's anything less left give
that to science
and actually this worked for
175 years we're still there we have
filled with the same structure we have
the calculate Foundation which owns the
company
um the company has grown a bit since
then we have now uh 38 000 employees we
make a bit of money and we have four
major areas we work in it's still all
optic related
and probably most of these things you
don't know because these are business to
business
areas where an End customer doesn't see
what's going on but I think most of you
have been in touch with devices
that Were Somehow in contact with size
equipment from all of these business
markets for example consumer markets
these are lenses not everyone wears a
lens but everybody looks movies and
among other things we produce high
quality Cinema lenses and a lot of
Hollywood blockbuster movies are made
with Vice lenses
um second thing is industrial quality
and research you maybe have used the
microscope front size at some point
probably not but you all have been
sitting in a cars and very many car
manufacturers use our surface
measurement and Technologies to measure
the shapes of their cars
areas medical technology I hope you have
not been in touch with that probably not
but uh
some might be
there's a story from last year's we are
developers conference where we had a
booth and some gay guy some some person
came along and he said okay that's a
great company I had eye surgery on one
of your laser systems and now my vision
is great again
and
fourth area is semiconductor
manufacturing technology
um
almost all of the computer chips so in
in your phone in your laptop are made on
our machines and this is what I'm going
to talk about today
so uh
let's talk about computer chips
you probably have heard about Moore's
Law
which means the number of transistors in
computer chips doubles every two years
and this has been the case for a very
long time and still will be the case for
uh
at least 10 to 15 years probably longer
the key ingredient for that is you
cannot just make more chips because you
don't want to grow the size of your
devices if you want to have you if you
want to have more transistors you have
to make each transistor smaller and this
shrinkage process is really the key to
the advancements in semiconductors
so how do you make these small
structures
actually it's not that hard to make
small structures there are a number of
Technologies where you can can write
very small structures up to Atomic level
but the difficult task is you just want
to make a few of them you want to have
billions of transistors on your chip and
you want to make billions of chips and
with the technology that's like a pencil
where you write everything else that
just doesn't work
so what you need is an extremely fast
copying machine
and that this is lithography
you write the chip once and you use this
template or mask and you you use Optics
projector to project that from The Mask
onto the Silicon wafer and then you can
make hundreds of copies on a silicon
wafer and this is a very very fast
process it's basically like stamping
um and to give you an analogy so this is
really like the transition from uh
handwriting to the book press where you
can make arbitrary many copies in almost
no time
so lithography is really the key factor
in making in this industrial scale
um
computer chips
and this is then again where we come
into play as an Optics company so so
this Digital Book press machine it's a
lithography scanner it's called it looks
like this
um and in the center part there's a lot
of stuff and electronics going out on
the outside the center part is really
the
um Imaging Arctic so you have the mask
at the top and you have the wafer there
at the bottom
and to give you an idea
um what it means to build something like
this we want to make we want to make
make very smart we want to image very
small structures this means our Optics
has to be ultra high precision
and what ultra high Precision means is
on a surface area of say about a meter I
have to have deviations from a defined
shape that are less than a tenth of a
nanometer
now
probably you don't have really an
intuition what it means what a tenth of
a nanometer is
so just to make a scale comparison if I
would blow up the size of this mirror to
the size of Germany
we would have to manufacture the surface
of Germany up to a Precision of about
the size of the hair
and
yeah that's that's the challenge in the
technology
um so um how do we do that
um when we go into developing such a
machine
um we have to
find out
what system do I want to build how do I
can I achieve
the Precision
and that really is strongly inter
dependent with my manufacturing process
for that machine because I can have some
theoretical idea how I want to build
something but I have to be able to build
that in production as well
so um
to be able to build these machines you
again need specialized machines
to build that
yeah so we cannot for some things we can
but for many things we cannot buy
Machines of the shelves because they
don't have the
requirements we need
sometimes we can order them custom
builds but more often than not we have
to build our own machines for our
production sites because they are very
specialized machines
so and if if we do that we we have an
interdependent cycle between the design
for the lithography Optics the process
the design for the machines which I want
to build for the process and this is a
large Circle so
um when you look into classical
and there's not just one machine you
build you have to build you have to
build a whole Factory of different
machines
um
so when you look into a classical
development process you come up with
some ideas I want you want to solve it
or some requirements
then you think of a solution and you
build a prototype and you either write
that for a couple of times check what's
good on the Prototype what you still
have to do better and
then at some point you say now we're
good enough we go into production
the problem here is if we wanted to
build a prototype for our lithography
Optics we would have to build a factory
with specialized with machines which we
would have to create to build the
Prototype and in the next iteration on
the Prototype we would have to throw
away half the factory because the the
next prototype had changed and this is
just not feasible it's not feasible
economically and it's not feasible
because of iteration Cycles you cannot
have prototype iteration cycles of
multiple years
so what we do is we don't pay prototypes
that means we have to simulate
everything
and all of a sudden from a very Hardware
related topic you end up in a world of
software
you end up with a lot of simulations you
learn the end of with a lot of data with
a lot of data analysis and that's
the
that's really a large change we are
currently making in our development
processes because they're they're more
and more getting
yeah
and um
so we really in our r d departments have
to think about software a lot and how do
we have to think about software
our domain experts our Engineers have
typically two different tasks
two different kinds of categories there
are standard tasks
where you
get some data have a known solution you
want to evaluate something maybe you get
something from production from
existing tools and you you would just
want to have done an analysis you want
to have in that case the engineers want
to have fixed tools where they put the
data in get the result out or maybe it's
even automated and nobody uh
it works in pipelines and nobody has to
do anything manually anymore
on the other hand
in r d you have this exploratory topics
when we design a new system we usually
don't know what we have to do at the
start
so the solution is unknown and of course
we build from existing knowledge but we
have to do modifications we have to do
additions
and step by step we have to try out
Solutions
and to be able to do that uh you sort of
need some building blocks in your
analysis tooling you don't want to build
everything from stretch and it also has
to be interactive because you do
something you look at the data that
produces and then based on that you
decide what's the next step
and both of this can be supported by a
software ecosystem
um and there are three properties in our
case which are essential to such an
ecosystem
the first thing is because it this
ecosystem is for research Engineers
um
it has to be domain language
we want to speak we want to express our
ideas of our problems in the domain
language
um
second is it has to be hierarchical
because we have to
um
we have very very complex systems which
we can analysis analyze on a very high
level say what's the overall performance
of the whole system but sometimes we
have to go into the very details of the
system so you have to manage that
complexity in this hierarchical
structure and the third aspect of the
system is software ecosystem is it needs
to be flexible because in r d we never
know what's the next idea and we have to
adapt to that
and this all can vary well be solved
with python actually
so this is our basic conceptual setup of
this ecosystem we have a lot of python
libraries
we use of course public python libraries
like an Umpire and so on but we build on
our own specialized libraries on top and
I will have a complete slide on
libraries on the next slide again
then we use these libraries to build the
standard tools
we also have more complex Frameworks for
simulation for example which we built on
these libraries and we also use these
libraries to interface with all kinds of
third-party software be it simple things
like Matlab or Excel or other very
specialized simulation solutions like
finite elements object simulation
computational fluid dynamics and
anything else you need there
now this ecosystem is used by our domain
experts to solve their
domain specific problems and it can be
that they have a problem that's served
by a standard tool so they just take the
standard tool out of the box and use the
problem but more often than not if they
are in this
development mode they take some of the
libraries they build some software
additional to that they make some
modifications there and build the
customized solution to their current
domain problem
So speaking of libraries
maybe you have seen this
image the Scientific Python ecosystem is
sort of organized in layers at the
foundational level you have Python and
the standard Library
then you have something like core
libraries for data structures and
visualization
then you have some specialized logic
libraries like for image processing for
statistic models for machine learning
and on the the outer scope you have
domain specific libraries this is now
the the public python ecosystem so
there's something like for astrophysics
for a biophysics and these things and
actually in our
internal python ecosystem we do the same
we use what's in there mainly from the
uh of course not from the outer layer
because we're not interested in
astrophysics physics usually but from
the inner layers and we build our own
libraries next to that which interact
with this ecosystem and this this
approach is really something I mean we
have seen it working in the python
ecosystem this works very well we have
the foundational libraries and if you
use for example scikit image they use
numpy as the data format and it all just
works too well together
so then there's uh one further aspect
which I want to mention
um a key
thing to build
a suitable software tools is that you
have to bring together the domain
knowledge and the software engineering
expertise to do so and as I said this
whole ecosystem setup we have is
targeted at our software domain our
domain experts they are also not
software experts we sort of have to
guarantee that this software is still
developed in the right way and um when
you have a research scientists they
usually have a lot of domain knowledge
and maybe have a bit of programming
knowledge they sort of can solve their
problem but the code is probably not
that elegant not that fast uh uh not not
that uh maintainable
and if things get more complex the code
starts to get a get to be a big ball of
mud and this is something also the
scientific research Community has
experienced and the idea here I present
is actually inspired by the concept of
research software engineering in
Academia they have exactly the same
problem they have hard domain specific
problems and they use data science
machine learning software to Links more
and more
and it's hard for them to uh work with
external software developers because
they usually don't understand the
problem correctly and what the idea
behind research software engineering is
that you have a second person on the
other side which still has some domain
knowledge but has a lot of software
engineering knowledge and I think this
is the the key idea in this
understanding that we don't have this
strict separation and say this is the
domain role you only have domain
knowledge you don't have any software
expertise and on the other hand you have
the software expert with just the
software knowledge and no domain
expertise but you
leverage the differences to a certain
extent you still have your core field of
competence but you are aware of the way
of thinking and the fundamental ideas of
the other field
and this appears to be really a
concept to address
heart domain problems with suitable
software
okay
um
so I think I'll skip this on if you want
to know about environment management you
can talk to me later
um so then I would like to conclude
um and um we have seen uh that
um we have an interplay between what
Carl's Ice does with the python and
computer chips you can read this
actually in two ways you can say what I
just showed you we at the is use Python
to enable the r d for the next
generation of computer chips but the
interdependence is also the other way
around because we have invested so much
in trip technology and we is not only
size but the whole industry we as
software developers are able to afford
being ineffective with python to a
certain extent to have a convenient
interface and this is really something
because computer chips also powerful we
can afford pipe
so to sum up I want to conclude with a
quote from Isaac Newton if I have seen
further than others it's by standing on
their shoulders of giants it's really an
interplay between different Industries
between different generations and we are
all just here because many clever people
have worked together in great ways
so thank you very much
um we have a booth at the other side of
the building if you want to come to us
do so we also have interesting job
offers thank you
thank you Mr Hoffman for the great
presentation now we can come to some
questions if you have any questions just
write them down at slido or vote up
questions already existing
and we come to question number one for
Optics simulations do you use an
in-house simulation solver or a
commercial solution if it is commercial
which one
we actually have in-house optic
simulation software because the
commercial soft one is not good enough
for the needs we have
could you show us an example of a
software solution
for a physical prototype
um sort of
um
if it takes too long just feel free to
yeah so um
this machine here
okay
okay we will go to another question
yeah next question please
how do you Tech scientists programming
and those becoming research software
engineers
yeah that's that's an interesting
question so so there are there are two
approaches you you can either take
people with domain knowledge and start
to teach them some software uh practices
and that's that's what we've been doing
a lot you can also do the different way
and say I'll hire some software experts
and educate them in our domain topics
that's something we are currently
doing more and more because we want to
strengthen also the software side more
just not not from the existing in-house
Knowles that then I'll just give you a
brief answer to the previous question so
this machine here is the machine so you
see here two people it's a bit a larger
machine to measure this surface accuracy
of uh 0.1 nanometers and to be able to
do that we uh in a very short we have to
understand the machine perfectly to get
rid of any side effects so we have have
a complex simulation system to build
that machine and this is what I've also
been working on the last two years
a question I think is very interesting
what do you think when will Moore's Law
finally fail
at some point we are not there so there
the the development Moore's Law is not
by coincidence it's it's an agreement by
the semiconductor industry
and the industry agrees on a road map
the roadmap goes currently 15 years
upwards so not before 2038
next question from the transistor
structure point of view where does the
journey go at the moment still film ffts
or our gaaafets the future
the transistor structure gets more and
more complex
I'm not the expert on the the individual
structures finfets are now sort of state
of the art nanotubes are something
that's coming up and in general if if
you put more effort in the complex three
design 3d design of a transistor you
usually get some additional benefits
compared to size and performance
what processes do you have established
in-house to ensure the details about for
example python software packaging are
out of the way for your develops yeah so
um that's actually the thing I didn't
mention
um
we try to
give as little as possible uh
um
environment uh
management to the end users so we have
predefined
environments which contain all our tools
which are directly installed to the
engineers they can just take them and
use them and we have a central
management for that including also
versioning and other things
what kind of products you develop in the
astrophysics or space engineering field
um
we have a vice semiconductor
manufacturing technology none we as a
company we have some some sort of Mala
side projects like mirrors for
telescopes and in satellites
but these are
small smaller almost pet projects I
would say
Did You observe friction between
research Engineers trying to develop
their own software Solutions and the s
team thinking that they do the right
code
yes so that's that's very common and it
happens all the time
one important thing is to make people
aware of their limits and their
boundaries in any positive sense yeah so
it's not your task to build a complex
simulation framework if if you just
script some parts of python so if you
are not you don't have any idea about
software architecture about about
devops and these things
leave these things to the people who
know what they are doing and on the
other hand we as as as a team have to
make sure that these uh
are taken care of so that the research
experts don't start to mess about with
these because it's not their their main
interested they just do it if they don't
have anybody else who does it for them
so if you help them if you give them the
right tools they are happy to use them
there's still more time for one more
question before lunch break
can you give some insights how domain
experts and software Engineers
collaborate at size
yeah so
[Music]
um
what's the best thing to say so we we
have this idea also between between
software domain experts and software
Engineers or research software Engineers
this has evolved over time so
historically we just had the domain
experts and they programmed a bit and as
10 years ago things were much simpler
that was enough then things became more
and more complex and the domain experts
had to do more and more and at some
point it started failing because things
got too complex because the software got
too complex and at some at that point
we really had to realize we need
additional competencies and we sort of
try to build that up internally
currently
um
yep maybe that's the thank you for your
talk for your presentation
[Applause]